listen to be able to wear a superhero
suit is is one thing and it's and it's
incredibly cool
but i never got to walk out to like the
arrow theme music when i was on set
[Applause]
what is kind of like a a heels 101 that
you want to tell the audience before
they tune in you don't have to know a
thing about wrestling to love this show
and i'm i'm speaking as a fan i didn't
know a thing about wrestling and i
couldn't put the scripts down and i
believe that the great you know the
greatest shows out there the greatest
movies out there you're dropped into a
world where you can relate to characters
who can't relate to working your ass off
to put food on the table or or wanting
more out of life but you're also going
to experience this incredible world and
if you don't know anything about it
you're going to learn a lot just echoing
what alexander said you can love
wrestling you can not know anything
about wrestling if you hate wrestling
don't watch the show go away
and but but you'll you'll get it you'll
get it right away your washed up
quarterback couldn't play in college i'm
a lawnmower salesman
it is not enough for me you both came
from long-running fan favorite series
aero vikings you've played your
characters for such a long time
take me back to that moment when you
were first in your full costume as jack
and ace for heels what was going through
your mind well
i i was thinking to myself maybe i
should have gone with full-length pants
as opposed to trunks
actually
nah i mean it was listen to be able to
wear a superhero suit is is one thing
and it's it's incredibly cool
but i never got to i never got to walk
out to like the arrow theme music when i
was on set whereas on heels you know we
have we have our entrance music and when
it hits and when the smoke machines go
off and
uh all the extras in the duffy dome who
were spectacular uh and really really
committed to the to the show in a
variety of ways
when they're booing and hissing and
or when ace is coming out to the ring
like it's just it's just a different
it's just a different feeling it doesn't
it doesn't require a lot of acting it
really doesn't except
except for me where i
i've got this big smile inside and this
look of disdain outside
they all cheer for me the cheer for the
character the character i play character
i created alexander it's so fun because
we see ace in quite a few vests but
they're very different than your viking
vest they're a lot less furry what was
that like for you to kind of embody
this
like guy who wants to be loved so badly
and and how are you liking the eyeliner
you know the eyeliner was actually my
choice i i thought it was it was pretty
fun and rock and roll yeah you know just
this whole experience with this show has
been so tremendous like even and i fell
in love with these scripts the second
they were sent to us and um it's it's
it's an actor's dream to get to play
because it's limitless this world is so
colorful and the second you put on these
outfits and you walk out into the ring
and as stephen said they're playing your
music and the audience is cheering i
mean you're there you're in it and um i
mean it's just been truly just an
incredible experience to be able to go
from one show that you're really really
proud of to another is um
it's just you know at the end of the day
we're storytellers and just so great to
tell a story that we're so proud of
ace can succeed at the highest level
it's a natural it's in his blood i
imagine the training for this show is a
whole different game for both of you
guys steven obviously you trained for
more than eight seasons to play oliver
queen on arrow what was the difference
of stepping into the ring for heels
versus stepping out to save star city on
arrow well on arrow
everyone was really left to their own
left to their own devices which
um
you know could get complicated if if my
schedule was really was really busy and
they weren't baking in the time for for
training whereas with heels right from
the get-go they built us a gym
and
they they baked in the training time so
you know it actually
while it was a while it was a lot more
physically demanding it was
easier to
stay in shape and feel good because
that everything was everything was baked
into your schedule so steven's had some
experience wrestling i never had any so
i i've had the fortune of working with
some of the greatest heels of all time
randomly like dwayne johnson or adam
copeland and i leaned on adam a lot
actually who who was ed she was a hall
of fame wrestler about you know what
exactly i should be doing but basically
it's unlike anything i've ever done
before it was without a doubt the most
extensive training i've done for
anything
um
and my respect for these men and women
who literally put their lives on the
line every single night to put on a show
and provide for their families um
it's just it's just tenfold since i
began and we we had people we could lean
on but we knew that we had to do right
by the wrestling community and
we know that people like we knew this
show was great the story is awesome
we're so proud of these characters but
we wanted the wrestling community to
watch this and go wow these guys really
put in the work and that was just a lot
of training uh you know if you weren't
in the gym you were in the ring um and
it was just this constant repetition
for eight months um
while covid was a thing so it was even
just it was just a surreal experience
yeah you were putting in a lot of work
but like yet somehow you've been finding
time for your music
[Music]
and it's been so fun to see that on your
instagram and then here we go episode
two ace goes to walk up on the stage for
karaoke and i'm like they're merging
these worlds it's so great and he starts
singing and i'm like that is not the
voice i was expecting
what are the chances that in season one
we could see ace actually croon a little
eight aces in the singer
and apparently jack is because here we
go in episode three yeah yeah
that's right maybe david can you can you
can you can you give us one really
quickly nice little uh when the times
are tough
[Music]
we got kids to come to the show ace
what's the matter do you afraid i'm
gonna go off script even have you shown
mavi any of your wrestling scenes this
whole show is not appropriate for her
yet but have you shown her snippets oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah she's seen
oh gosh she's seen three episodes what i
think and um
you know she she just knows that if um
she just knows that
if wild bills on the screen and or ace
and crystal are on the screen
that it's uh it's time it's time to
cover the eyes that's it
the full eye cover that's you know it's
like whatever i love the fact that we
did get to see cass in a couple episodes
of arrow what are the chances we'll get
a cast cameo in heels i don't know um
that would be fun yeah i'm more we i'm
more interested in the uh in the lauren
ludwig cameo that we get in episode two
break it down how did that happen
my i almost broke up with me i
because with kovid you can't bring
people on to set yeah okay i'm gonna
sign her up as an extra she'll get
tested and she'll be able to come on set
and see what we do she's never seen
anything like this um
and of course it's a 14-hour day and
she's just like alexander like if she
hates being in front of the camera she's
like i'm going to leave you if you do
this again
which scene was she in he's a bartender
in uh in in
an episode
so when you're yelling at someone
because you want more whiskey you're
yelling at your wife yeah exactly
[Music]